i believe
many years ago you met with spielberg
about writing a fourth indiana jones
movie
yeah did you ever come up with your
mcguffin and the idea or was it more
just like a basic meeting
oh my god it was it was i mean it was
fantastic you know obviously raiders
is like you know my favorite movie of
all time and so this was a dream
um like you know to be asked as a kid to
go see
a movie in a movie theater then later to
be asked by that person to write one of
those in the future i mean
that's his you know i mean i like you
could pin you know faint i could faint
at that moment it was amazing
um i do have my notebooks i still have
those with all my ideas for
for that movie i did have i did have a
take i did have a take
um i talked to everybody involved and it
was so nascent at that time that movie
so ever no one had gotten
everyone hadn't gotten into a room yet
they were kind of bouncing ideas off of
me
so everyone had different ideas of
of what to do but i ha i definitely when
you say that i have in my head
and like it's a green notebook and i i i
had this idea it was it was
it was a darker idea
god did you because every every you know
uh indiana jones movie has the mcguffin
so but had you thought about what that
was yet
i i i did i did yeah i hadn't
i looked i hadn't i hadn't pitched it to
them or anything like that but i had
an idea